my name is Cedric Necaise I'm the wine
director at Eleven Madison Park and we
are here today to talk about wine labels
why they're important what's written on
them and how it relates to what's in the
bottle so we're gonna start with
something that everyone is familiar with
which is California Cabernet starting at
the very top of the label and then
working down so vintage 2010 important
note about vintage is that it is when
the grapes were picked or harvested not
when the wine was released or actually
bottled it's really important to know
your own taste some people really like
young very full very kind of up front
wines and some people like older wines
are a little more subtle a little bit
earthy err and less tannic the actual
age of the wine matters less than
actually knowing what happened during
that vintage so if it was warm vintage
wines a riper it's cool vintage wines
are less ripe and lower in alcohol there
are some times where there's fires in a
wine region which will affect the grapes
if it rained a lot all those things are
much more important than your personal
preference of liking older wine or
younger wine then moving down to the
producer in this case the Knightsbridge
producer in of Cabernet Sauvignon the
varietal here on the label and then
below that the winery itself in Knights
Valley and Knights Valley an area in
California those two or those three
things put together is a terroir terroir
is the summation of everything that goes
into making a bottle of wine the type of
soil that is grown on the amount of rain
that falls the amount of sunshine to the
heat during the day and heat at night
the type of fertilizer anything that can
go into producing a bottle line is the
terroir of the wine lastly on this label
is the alcohol percentage generally the
higher the alcohol the riper the grapes
the sweeter the fruit the richer the
wine will be so in this case 14.9%
alcohol you know that's a pretty full
body pretty rich velvety flavored wine
with lots of fruit alcohol is certainly
the most important indicator for how
full-bodied a wine will be so you see
with 16% alcohol and label you shouldn't
automatically know that it's very
full-bodied very rich not just high in
alcohol